there was no other person like her you
know there's there's no other person
he'd even could come kind of close to
who she was she was a standard for
living well and being proud and taking
who you are and owning who you are and
using it to the fullest share Oprah
Winfrey and Gayle King reflect on Tina
Turner's Life and Legacy
[Music]
news broke that the music icon died at
83 and it didn't take long for her
famous friends to start sharing touching
tributes like share I thought you know I
need to put this time in here into our
friendship so that she knows that we
haven't forgotten her so we kind of all
took turns going and spending time with
her Cher called into msnbc's the beat
with Ari melber and opened up about her
recent visits with Tina she fought this
sickness for such a long time and she
was
so strong but towards the end I know
that she told me one she said I'm really
ready you know I just don't want to put
up with this anymore Oprah and Gail
echoed that on CBS mornings I went gone
to visit her in the hospital in 2019 and
she had said to me then that she
actually was ready to go with the
meaning ready to leave the planet and uh
I expected then that that was going to
be the last time that I saw her her
husband Erin Bach literally willed her
to live Tina married Irwin Bach a music
producer in 2013 after 27 years together
she was 16 years his senior I found him
quite attractive and I made it known to
him and I wasn't thinking about age
Urban is quite conservative
and I'm still quite youthful for my age
so there's a there is a meeting point of
where we uh communicate in that way
prior to that the singer had a
tumultuous relationship with Ike Turner
that you were married from 1962 to
1978. I tried to get out a few times and
I didn't succeed I felt trapped but I
wanted too much more and I was not gonna
let anything take that away from me at
that stage when I first knew her she was
still with Ike and that was kind of a
very strange
um very strange to see her with I can to
see her afterwards
and and I was so thrilled because
afterwards she was so free and you could
just see her like being able to take a
big breath once she left the abuse she'd
be she she became a Clarion call of
Triumph for other women I'm proud to be
able to have you know call her call her
a friend but I would have been happy
just being a groupie yes Oprah appeared
in the 2021 HBO documentary Tina about
the Grammy Winner's life
I got the spirit is no different than
being in a church where you are moved
and stirred to the point where you could
feel it inside yourself and on Tuesday
the TV Legend penned a lengthy essay
about the impact Tina had on her life
writing in part I am a better woman a
better human because her life touched
mine
[Music]